Goldman Sachs is now offering Bitcoin
and ethereum to many of their High net
worth clients this is a huge deal
because Goldman Sachs is one of the
biggest banks in the world it is the
second largest Investment Bank they have
two trillion dollars in assets under
management market cap of 111 billion
dollars 40 000 employees and Goldman's
private wealth management business
mostly targets people that got at least
25 million dollars or more to invest now
when we start to think about why it is
so important that they are starting to
offer Bitcoin and ethereum to their High
net worth clients it's because that is
the first step to offering to all of
their clients and when you have two
trillion dollars in assets you don't
need much of that to shift into Bitcoin
cryptocurrencies in order to start to
see price impacted we've got a quote
here from Mary Rich the global head of
digital assets for Goldman's private
wealth management division Mary said
there's a contingent of clients who are
looking to this asset as a hedge against
inflation and the macro backdrop over
the past year I certainly played into
that she then went on to say there is
also a large contingent of clients who
feel it we're sitting at the dawn of a
new internet in some ways and are
looking for ways to participate in this
space when we start to think about
exactly how these clients are being the
ones pulling the bank into the space
that's important because if the banks
were simply sitting around a conference
room and they were saying to themselves
I don't know if anyone wants this maybe
we should do it maybe we shouldn't they
begin to prioritize how are we actually
going to spend our budget this year and
what is the potential Roi but when your
clients are quite literally banging down
your door saying get me into this Market
get me exposure to these assets you as a
bank no either you help them do it or
they'll go somewhere else we then have a
quote from Mike novogratz the founder
and CEO of Galaxy digital he also used
to be a partner at Goldman Sachs where
he said adoption is happening faster
than I predicted it's shocking to me how
fast people are moving into the system
and of course we've seen individuals
we've seen financial institutions and
even nation states start to adopt this
technology but over time what one thing
is clear is that Wall Street regardless
of what they thought about it initially
they have to participate their clients
are demanding it and Goldman Sachs is
proving that by getting in the game and
offering Bitcoin and ethereum to their
private wealth clients
what do you think Goldman Sachs this is
a great move Morgan Stanley has already
made this move and they're going to go
ahead and let clients invest in Bitcoin
in April this is a no-brainer for
Goldman Sachs the second largest
Investment Bank in the world right
behind JPMorgan who I expect to follow
this lead and also do a similar move
this year as well
um but yeah they're a massive company
with
um
with clients that have massive amounts
of wealth and having those clients the
ability to access Bitcoin and invest in
the asset to either push the price up or
just for them personally to get exposure
to them it's great for the client great
for them and I'm sure the bank will
figure out a way to make a ton of money
off fees off uh exchange fees and
custody fees and everything in between
um so they're going to make money as
well so it's good for everyone
I think also uh the clients that they
have in the private wealth uh division
they're very sophisticated now some
people may say they make bad trades
whatever right that's true anywhere just
because uh because you're rich doesn't
make you smart but they are very
sophisticated for the most part and uh
it's another signal that this is not
just people playing on the internet that
are random that no one's ever uh thought
of as a sophisticated investor instead
what we're talking about here is some of
the wealthiest people in the world are
now saying Hey I want exposure to that
asset class and in the short term sure
there'll be some price impact on that uh
probably bullish if there's more people
putting a lot of dollars in but I think
the more important thing to me is these
people they aren't very price sensitive
in terms of uh trading around a lot of
these folks they're family offices
they're they're large investors and so
what they do is they come up with a
number okay I want to put two percent of
my assets into Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they go ahead and they
allocate to that space and as they do
that what they watch is whether it goes
up it goes down it goes sideways
whatever they've allocated and they're
going going to continue to hold that
position very few of them are day
trading or anything like that if they're
using the private wealth management at
Goldman Sachs or anywhere else so it's
interesting to see these people coming
into uh into the market I also think
that uh another piece of it is if
Goldman is doing this it must mean that
the top Executives all uh bless this
this doesn't get done because there's a
reputational component to it there's a
risk management component to it Etc
there's definitely okay they went and
they got anointed by the executive team
and said you're good to go go offer it
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure to
subscribe like the video and see you
next time